Londres dans les années 1960, tout le monde a une histoire
sur le Christ Je viens ici pour une bonne
fusillade tu me donnes le rouleau à
pâtisserie ça me fera un gâteau riche tu veux de l'argent
pour la bataille ouais ce sont les
jumeaux Kray Ronald et Reginald tu me
coupes le souffle  loin tu dois être Frances Hé tu
penses que nous ressemblons à la vie marine étant un
gangster J'aime l'argent et le
respect ton frère pourri est Island et
psychopathe il est hors de son rocker
bien non non non non monsieur notre droit est un
défi de chanson comme une liste vous  Je parle
d'être des gangsters, c'est ce que nous
sommes.
il fait chaud c'est parfois
génial mais je n'ai PAS de préjugés
tu as beaucoup de couilles pour faire ce gâteau
n'abandonnera pas vivre une règle en vertu de laquelle
ils ne rient pas ou ne meurent pas oh ouais
es-tu fou de faire quelque chose à propos du rock je
ne peux pas faire ça  c'est mon frère
je veux vivre ça si s  il sait trop de
choses nous on descend dans les
égouts
après les Krays ma chance pour mon frère
c'est que ça me manque moi-même et
tu n'as pas de dents le crime principal
est toujours un business tu ne veux pas de guerre
ouais attaaaack état
écoutez-vous ou vous n'êtes pas le sang
est plus épais que l'eau
nous sommes
vous ne trouverez rien beaucoup de vous
-même et vous
vous